alain leboeuf bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
alors beaucoup d'émotion aujourd'hui
dans la communauté catholique et au delà
pour commencer comment est ce que vous
avez réagi à l'annoncé de ce drame
oui effectivement beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotions en vendée pour nous la petite
commune de saint laurent sur sèvre est
une commune plus qu paisible et notre
communauté des pères que l'on connaît
parfaitement bien et est une communauté
de terre d'abord et d'ouverture
donc aujourd'hui c'est l'incompréhension
totale comment on peut donner sens à la
vie d'un prêtre qui respire la joie de
vivre qui a toujours partagé la plaie
que ce soit sur le territoire
départemental vont bien au delà puisque
il était souvent sur l'afrique a donné
ce message d'amour de tolérance et de
plaies alors on l'a entendu une
communauté des frères missionnaires de
mont fortin qui avait un certain
rayonnement dans votre région concernant
les faits maintenant quels sont les
éléments dont vous disposez sur le
déroulé de ce drame qu'ont coûtés on a
appris très dernièrement que même moi en
tant que président du département je ne
le savais pas que cet homme était
hébergé à la congrégation à sa lorente
et ensuite tout s'est déroulé très vite
mon premier vice-président était encore
hier avec le père olivier maire est tous
passés tout à fait normalement
c'est donc pendant cette matinée que
tout s'est précipité où on a appris cet
homicide
inexplicable en tous les cas pour le
long d un homicide
inexplicable qui a fait beaucoup réagir
cependant beaucoup de réactions
politiques on le voyait de la tristesse
mais aussi de la colère notamment par
rapport au profil du suspect un homme
d'origine rwandaise déjà mises en examen
pour l'incendié de la cathédrale de
nantes
c'était en juillet 2020 selon vous
est-ce que ce drame
il révèle des failles notamment au
niveau de la justice
écoutez j'entends beaucoup de remarques
effectivement
beaucoup de mes collègues se prononcent
d'ores et déjà personnellement en tant
que président du département de la
vendée pour l'instant je veux rester en
seul le fait et de recueillement mais
néanmois néanmoins viendra le moment où
il va falloir qu on donne quelques
explications effectivement comment est
ce possible qu'on en arrive à de tels
faits extrêmes lorsque l'on a un passé
comme celui que vous l'êtes décrire le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
et est attendu dans quelques minutes sur
place
qu'est ce que vous attendez de lui ce
soir on sait qu'ils ont conçu le
ministre la correction minimal de venir
donc nous réconforter essayer de
comprendre mais dans un second temps il
va falloir que nous ayons des
explications mais encore une fois le
premier temps se fera de partager ce qui
fait passer
très concrètement dans ses dernières
heures afin de rentrer social dans notre
congrégation des pères montfortains
parce qu'effectivement vous vous disiez
que le suspect finalement personne
n'était au courant
de sa présence dans cette communauté ou
la gendarmerie la justice savait que
cette personne était accueilli par le
père olivier maire je devine que justice
devait être informée néanmoins nous ne
l'étions absolument pas c'était sans
doute des échanges entre la congrégation
elle-même et la justice mais je ne peux
pas en dire plus parce que je n'en sais
pas plus alors beaucoup nous en méchant
joue
merci beaucoup à la leboeuf d'avoir
réagi en direct sur rt france je le
rappelle vous êtes président du conseil
départemental de vendée